[Music]
alright let's talk about the book right
here in front of me enlightenment now
I've been kicking around this phrase on
Twitter that's called a little traction
that we are now in the unlighted
because it seems like we're in this
endless stream of constant stupidity and
some of it seems social media related
and we touched a little bit on that on
part one and when I'm saying it I'm
saying it a little tongue-in-cheek and
actually this book is sort of the answer
to I think what I'm calling the
Enlightenment that there are so many
good things happening right now and it's
very hopeful and optimistic and I always
tell people I'm an optimist otherwise I
couldn't do this you know I mean I I
feel that we there's a chance we can
make things better so first off let's
just do some one-on-one stuff here what
are enlightenment values to you well I
characterize them in the subtitle of
book as reason science humanism and
progress reason that we should analyze
our situation our predicament using the
most rigorous logic that we can and
rather than relying on Dogma Authority
traditional scripture not for social
media for social media although at least
throwing ideas out there is as long as
they get evaluators as long as they get
criticized right science namely that we
should test our hypotheses seek deep
explanations and the science provides us
not just with gadgets and cures for
disease although it's important that it
does that but also defines our human
condition that that concepts from
science like evolution like entropy like
the whole naturalistic worldview that
the laws of nature do their thing
without caring about us these are things
that we have to understand as the most
basic facts about our existence so the
audience's part has to be part of our
world to you then humanism is the idea
that it's human beings and other
sentient animals that deserve our moral
concern as opposed to they say the glory
of the tribe or
following carrying out religious
dictates or the faith or some messianic
age that it's just do people live long
healthy happy stimulating lives that's
what we should care about and promises
that if we use a reason in science to
make people better off well maybe we can
gradually succeed yeah so it's funny
when I when I was reading this and the
only word that like dinged a little
something in my head was progress and I
think it's partly because of the way
progressives have used progress that
progress in and of itself you want to
progress meaning have more and more
opportunity for people more and more
equality for people I think that's a far
cry from what I think the progressives
are doing right now because that that's
the most subjective one of any of those
terms right well I I have the wisecrack
that progressives hate progress look at
the people who denied that we've made
progress it's often the people who
politically label themselves as
progressive who can't stand the idea we
made progress because they want to say
that every aspect of our current society
and institutions as you know corrupt and
racist and controlled by the by the 1%
and everything is getting worse and
worse and worse
ironically because the whole point of
being a progressive presumably is that
progressive activism is not a waste of
time but it actually brings benefits and
which actually has sort of the catch-22
of progress in general that you have to
acknowledge it but in a weird way you
need to not acknowledge it to keep
furthering it yeah so there is an
optimum amount and one has to keep in
mind the two ideas that we've made
progress but we've got huge challenges
ahead of us and just a very simple
example extreme poverty the bare minimum
that you that you need to feed your
family has been has been falling and
that's it's got to be an example of
progress in a couple of hundred years
ago you could say that probably ninety
percent of humanity was lived in extreme
poverty now it's less than ten percent
that's amazing yeah a lot of that
happened just in the last thirty years
but another way of stating the same fact
is that seven hundred thirty million
people live in extreme poverty now
that's the same fact ten percent of 7.3
billion seven hundred
that's an awful lot of miserable people
now those are the same class described
in two different ways and we got to be
able to think in both ways and let's try
to get it to zero now that's not a crazy
romantic utopian starry-eyed goal that
is one of the UN sustainable development
goals the predecessor the Millennium
Development Goals for poverty was
reached five years ahead of schedule so
the new goal in which is to eliminate
extreme poverty everywhere by 2030
probably a little too optimistic but but
not not completely crazy and maybe it'll
be instead of 0% maybe it'll be 2% and
maybe it'll be 2040 but still it's an
amazing aspiration in the first place
yeah how much of this do you think and
this a little bit gets back to the blank
slate but how much of this do you think
the way you view progress whether the
acknowledgement of progress or that you
sort of need to feel that we've made no
progress to kind of fuel yourself how
much of that do you think is just
hardwired and the way we look at the
world I think some of it comes from
certain cognitive biases one of them
being the availability heuristic named
discovered by Daniel Kahneman and Amos
Tversky namely the human mind generally
estimates probability and risk by
calling examples from memory if you've
just seen a tornado on the news then you
think that tornadoes are a major cause
of death and the fact that you know
falls off ladders kill many more people
than tornadoes doesn't register because
those don't make the news and and we
don't net naturally calibrate for how
many opportunities there are for bad
things to happen how big the world is
how many people there are we just
remember the examples and that's what
drives our intuitions and when you have
the news media reporting everything that
goes wrong everywhere then you can come
away with an impression of the world is
falling apart because all the parts of
the world that aren't falling apart
never make the news yeah that's one
there is also a we are I think
tuned to dwell on the negative probably
because bad things can hurt you a lot
more than good things can help you so
there is something adaptive in a natural
environment to you know be on the
lookout for
and kill you so that's just a survival
and that's I think it's a part of the
survival instinct there are there other
things too like the there's always
implicit competition between different
elites in society the academics the
journalists the politicians the
businesspeople the religious the
military you know they're all different
kind of power centers and they all kind
of compete with each other for prestige
and an influence and if you say society
is declining it's corrupt it's a mess
it's horrible
kind of a way of each one of these
groups can kind of feel superior to the
others the academics could say look what
the businessman the contrarian a
businessman can say look what the
politicians are doing to the country and
the challengers can say look at the
incumbents are doing and so it's it's
kind of a backhanded way of social
one-upmanship yeah do you sense that
right now we're at a unique position to
bring back more enlightenment values
like it seems to me that because of
Trump because of social media that just
everything is sort of upside down right
now this again has been a theme with a
bunch of I guess that everything is sort
of on the table and that there's great
opportunity we don't know which way it's
gonna go but there's great opportunity
for good ideas there's a great
opportunity for bad ideas obviously I
know which way we're both hoping this is
gonna yes but do you think that we
actually are in a unique moment right
now I know everyone always thinks that
they're always there they're always in a
tense moment right but do you think
there's something unique right now well
it's this way I just think that it's
kind of like inequality of a reset of
reason maybe growing that at the top
there's so many areas in which we become
so much more irrational and reasonable
like evidence-based medicine used to be
your doctor had a hunch and operated are
you gave you a drug and there's no
reason to think they would actually work
and now therapies are a value a to do in
big studies or a data-driven policing
one of the reasons that the crime rate
went down so dramatically starting in
the 90s is that the police started to
gather block by block data and where the
violence was occurring they kind of
collapsed on those areas like a ton of
bricks make sure that you know one gang
member
it just suffered a an injury wouldn't be
roaring for a revenge saying you know
we're watching you and that really drove
down the rate of crime by a lot hmm in
in sports sabermetrics and Moneyball
much more rational analysis
there's the effective altruism movement
how can we allocate charity and
volunteering so it actually does good as
opposed to just giving people a warm
glow so that all of these areas but at
the same time you get these nutball
conspiracy theories and the fake news
and the politicized denial of science
such as vaccine safety and climate
change so the question is how do we let
the standards of rationality make use
wouldn't trickle-down make it so that
that it's kind of second nature for
everyone to just not think in certain
ways because they've just been proven to
be obviously ridiculous yeah how do you
do it I mean I think that's a good I may
not be the one to you know to change a
whole society I do it by appealing to
the kind of people who watch this show
kind of people who read my books in the
hopes that it will kind of spread out
from there and we know it's not it's not
that it can't happen there are certain
bad ideas that at one point are taken
seriously and then they just drop off
and like no one talks about them ever
again you know like just you know my
lifetime when I was a kid there's a
debate over racial segregation you know
should should black students be admitted
to the University of Mississippi I mean
you just couldn't have that debate
anymore even among the farthest right or
the right yeah that's just no longer an
issue should women be allowed to to work
and in earlier decades and centuries it
was slavery or women's suffrage and
superstitions like you know alchemy or
human sacrifice so it's not hopeless
that sometimes what happens is that at
any given time there's a range of
reasonableness but that that Center
drifts so that some things that were at
the tail end of ridiculousness
even the conspiracy theory mongers and
the most benighted
can no longer take us seriously yeah how
much of this is just sort of our or the
discussion around all this is just about
our lack of patience because actually
when the when the publisher sent me the
the book I said enlightenment now and as
you guys had the font now he's bigger
than enlightenment and I thought that
was kind of interesting because we live
in a time of immediate reaction to
everything and selfies and likes and
people just don't have patience anymore
attention spans are incredibly short
that we want more now but some of these
things are just the long game yeah I
think that's it that's exactly right we
also we have amnesia for how things were
not so long ago yeah that's a point that
I make repeatedly even though there are
you know there there's a horrific war
going on now in Syria but we forget some
of the horrific wars that were going on
in the eighties and nineties yeah what
can we do to stop that amnesia cuz I
think that's a big part of this yeah and
I think the culture of journalism should
should put events of the day into some
context now I mean going back to you
know hundreds of years the American
Revolution but even just you know what
was like in the 1990s what was likely
the eighties because likewise who the
economy people are so nostalgic for the
early areas with strong unions and
predictable wages and factory jobs but
you know that was also the era of
double-digit inflation eighteen percent
inflation if you could pay the rent this
year you didn't know whether you could
pay it next year because it it could go
up by and you kind of forget about those
days long lines around the block to
their gasoline so the fear that we'd run
out of heating oil and we feel freeze in
the winter you high rates of poverty
among elderly people that have been
brought down by Social Security so are
just a commentary should look back
they're not ancient history but recent
history yeah what are some of the other
things that are that are hopeful right
now are there are other markers in
society or in science or politics are
there any other trends that you're
seeing right now that you think are
leading us to some positive places well
often you get pleasant surprises
you actually look at trends instead of
headlines mm-hmm and you and I were
talking about just off-camera about a
recent survey that showed that contrary
to the fears of a millennial generation
being intolerant of free speech and then
for that matter the society as a whole
and especially university campuses if
you actually this course this new study
anyway you actually plot the data we ask
people should people who are espousing
controversial beliefs at least be able
to save them it's actually been going up
it's higher among the college educated
than the the less college educated it
spans a range of controversial positions
it's true for Millennials as well as
baby boomers and so that what I myself
even experienced as a kind of dread and
foreboding about a whole generation
being intolerant of competing news turns
out to be probably overblown there a lot
of examples like that and there are
other positive developments I mean the
high school students protesting are
ridiculous gun safety laws that kind of
something that we couldn't have
predicted so recently the the me2
movement has had a lot of excesses and
you know I think that there's much to
criticize on the other hand it's not
okay for women to be preyed upon by
their bosses and that has suddenly
become an issue and probably the society
will on the whole change for the better
because of it I wasn't planning on going
here but since you mentioned it what
would it be a humanistic enlightened way
of looking at guns right now oh yeah
well some of it has to start with with
good data because a lot of our
stereotypes of just you know may be
right might be wrong you know on the
right they believe you have concealed
carry laws then that will reduce crime
on the left there's if we control guns
that will reduce homicide so we got to
be humble and try to get as many studies
as possible to know what will really
make a difference and what won't but in
general the idea that that we're better
off if we're we individually are not the
kind of judge or jury and executioner
right that one of the great advances of
civilization was that you out
justice to a disinterested third party
namely the court system rice and that
the idea that safety comes from
individuals defending their interests
with guns his will in fact almost
certainly has led to high rates of
violence
do you fear though that we couldn't wear
that we often give too much power to the
state I mean I think in in some areas we
do but I think the idea that people
should have guns so that they should
resist the the government you know the
kind of David Koresh and Idaho cults
that is a terrible idea the idea that we
should resist the government with with
guns I mean that's what they do in you
know in Congo that's ivali huh we have
this thing called democracy yeah so if
the government becomes too repressive we
speak out against it we vote we petition
we form organizations the idea that
we're gonna shoot back at the police I
mean that that's nuts
yeah what do you think of the state of
our democracy in general because I think
we're breaking off into these different
factions now where I mean I think some
people genuinely think that you know
this hashtag resistance that were under
this horrific authoritarian regime we
think we don't even have to get into
trumpet specifically if you don't want
but what do you think of just sort of
the the the systems that are in place
the branches of government all of the
the documents that founded this are they
doing all right at the moment so so you
know there are a lot of we by any
standards of world history we live in
fantastic freedom yeah you know I could
say that you know Trump is a and
he's a fascist and I don't worry about
being put in jail and that's a real
something to take yeah not to take for
granted if I said the equivalent in
Turkey I would be put in jail or in
Venezuela is that a little bit of the
short memory on some of the other things
why you need to know history because I
think that all the time I see these guys
all over Twitter vidiians it's amazing
yeah you can say whatever you really can
and we should not take that for granted
it's partly history but also partly
comparisons across countries and then
history remembering fascism and
communist
and looking at regions today like like
turkey and Venezuela and Russia there's
that it the what's not so healthy is
like gerrymandering that obviously
subvert a subversion of democracy the
effects of lobbying and campaign
contributions from the the wealthiest
that can't be a good idea the fact that
our elections dragged on for a year and
depends so much on on a cash is a
problem and there are government
bureaucracies that have gotten too big
and too too many regulations that don't
actually do anything beneficial I don't
think that means that's a call for just
reducing regulation you know that with a
meat cleaver because some regulations
really have done done good we've got
cleaner air we've got less poverty but
we should at least analyze what
government programs are cost-effective
and which ones are just a nuisance and a
drag yeah and even having that
conversation then gets people crazed
where I personally I come from it from a
little more of a libertarian perspective
and I would usually say that these days
we've got people like Alan musk that can
get us to Mars and that can help clean
the environment and green energy and all
of those things where I know there's
just another set of people that think
well we just can't leave it to the
industrialists we have to leave it to
the government that's at least a place
where we can have some respectful yes
agreement that's a that's a great place
to that's the conversation we should be
having and I my views that there has to
be a mix of policy and regulation and a
private enterprise I and and all and
with all the creativity and innovation
and bottom-up diversity that so an
example would be one thing that the
government can do and that private
industry can't do is put a price on
carbon emissions this is a position that
both left-wing and right-wing economists
favor but having done that then the
private sector can come up with a
technology to reduce co2 and it
shouldn't be up to the government to say
this this company is the one that we're
going to have support right and that's
where the the free market really does a
better job but having that that
discussion and and I think libertarians
deserve credit for raising an issue that
people
on the left just don't even think of
like just because you have good
intentions and you have a program with a
goal of achieving some good doesn't mean
it's gonna work yeah total waste of
money well that's what I think so much
of it is it sounds good it all sounds
good we want the government to do all
these things and then we know that in
practice often although you've laid out
a case for some of these things that
actually do work cleaner air here I mean
we're in Los Angeles the air is cleaner
really it had a lot to do with the
government for sure so I absolutely
acknowledge that but to me it seems like
so much of it feels like it's it sounds
good let's just sort of hand it to the
government and then you end up creating
a whole series of other problems that
are from fiscal things to all sorts of
other things yeah I mean I think
actually in some ways liberals have been
their own worst enemy in not being
willing to have that conversation and
almost like the platform is if you
support government programs you're a
good person if you post them you're a
bad person yeah whereas the the
discussion really should be which
government programs make us better off
repay their costs clean up the air
reduce poverty which ones are
boondoggles or bureaucracies and that
way even the people who are liberals
could at least have some ammunition and
say well don't don't kill that program
it actually works yeah and I have in the
book a graph of the environmental
quality since the EPA was initiated in
1970 by Richard Nixon as it turns out
and the population is increased by 40%
GDP increased by two and a half we've
driven twice as many miles but air
pollution is reduced by 60% so and that
almost so we wouldn't have just happened
with market innovation because there's
just no no one individually has an
incentive to not pollute that's the kind
of thing where governments can make a
difference likewise poverty there are
certain measures like the Earned Income
Tax Credit which is a kind of negative
income tax where almost everyone who
right and left who examines and says
that's a government program that really
worked it's kind of cheap so automatic
and it really did reduce poverty in the
lower middle class and working poor and
we need to have that discussion so that
the Liberals for that matter can say
well this program works don't cut it
I don't think but even they have kind of
disarmed on the often on the evidentiary
debate and just made it moralistic yeah
I think that's what so many of us that I
would include in this new group have you
heard this phrase intellectual darkweb
has this habit
does this sum across your desk yeah I
mean do you do you sort of catch what I
mean I think that I don't know who's to
say what it is or who is in it or
whatever but it strikes me that you're
sort of one of the people that's right
they're just people that are all coming
together because we're just trying to
get a little bit of the answers here
which really is what this is about
yeah and the way Jonathan Hyde calls it
is viewpoint diversity that it's a it's
not pushing a particular ideology but
it's getting a set of ideas out there
that that have to say have to struggle
they don't they don't get a pass the
whole point of mentioning them is that
okay now now attack them see if they
survive is there a piece of America
right now or I guess we could say this
in the West in general that our freedoms
have gotten so good actually that we
can't really figure out what's bad so
for example like during the the whole
debate over the football players
kneeling for the anthem I was watching
people and everyone's just screaming
about everything and half the people
hate Trump half the people say the
football players are at the American and
half the people turn it on the the
owners of the teams but I tried to lay
out a case that actually the entire
thing worked the way it was supposed to
in a free society Trump said something
but he didn't whether you agree with
what he said or not about mocking the
players he didn't try to pass a law
about it it's okay yes so he exercises
his free speech it's important to
recognize that that's he has that right
to if he had tried to pass a law that's
a different thing the players could
either kneel or not kneel they might
have to deal with the repercussions of
that the owners could decide whether
they wanted to keep those players on
their teams or not the fans could decide
if they wanted to not buy jerseys or not
or not attend games right but to me it
was actually like a puzzle of freedom
actually working and yet every day for
months if people were screaming that
this is you know that this is the
tyrannical regime
and everything so horrible does that
sort of jive with you that that we've
gotten to a place where we don't our
freedoms are so great that we're making
these these mountains out of things that
that are important to talk about but
yeah I think that's a good I think
that's a good analysis I mean I think
it's so it's a way of appreciating what
other countries would would die for I
mean you just couldn't have that
football players or soccer players
kneeling in you know in Turkey right or
just government policy I mean they'd be
in jail yeah Turkey one of our ala you
know allies that you ought to use air
quotes
yeah but yes I guess I think sort of a
good point yeah yeah so before we finish
up here give me give me a few more
things to just feel hopeful about cuz I
think that really is what you're you're
trying to show people that there's so
much goodness right now and let's not
lose that yeah well here some some
heartening facts the the Flynn effect
that IQ scores have been rising by three
points a decade for almost a century
something I know incredible as it may
sound yeah this is a really well written
to that one a little I spent too much
time on Twitter certainly the fact that
extreme poverty has been plummeting I
think is one of the greatest things
that's ever happened I mean literally
from seventy five percent reduction just
in 30 years in global rate of extreme
poverty and the rise of literacy 90
percent of the world's population under
the age of 25 can read and write and
there's almost perfect parity now
between girls and boys that's
encouraging diseases infectious diseases
are are in decline malaria tuberculosis
diarrhea and we vanquished smallpox just
sent it off into the the the into
ancient history it's an no longer a
disease there we might do the same thing
with polio with guinea worm is terrific
progress being made the and values of
toleration and what I think we'd all
agree our progressive values such as
toleration of homosexuality and women's
equality of the right to get a divorce
of political participation those have
believe it or not all been in in
gradually increase in every part of the
world even in the most politically
backward part of the world
Middle East to North Africa there's been
an increase with especially when you
compare generations when the younger
generations are much more open and
sympathetic to liberal values than at
the older generation and there's a
widespread illusion
everyone thinks that everyone else is
more reactionary than they really are
people say well I'm kind of progressive
but everyone around me contractionary
there's a huge gap in how tolerant
people really are and in how tolerant
they think everyone else is yeah it's
really interesting all right so so in
summation we should feel good about for
the future but we have to fight for it
right we we should be recognized what
we're in danger of losing we should
recognize what we've accomplished as a
kind of impetus to do more Steven Pinker
it's been an absolute pleasure thank you
for doing mine thanks for having me and
for more on Steven check out his new
book enlightenment now the case for
reason science humanism and progress
which we've linked to right down below
[Music]
you